here is Karin Jean-Pierre our black
lesbian press secretary denying that the
administration worked with Twitter to
censor posts I suspect she's going to
regret this one because Elon is sitting
on a treasure Trove of stuff but here
she is Twitter uh Elon Musk this week
fired the former FBI general counsel Jim
Baker who was serving as a top Twitter
lawyer musk alleges that he may have
been involved with counterbanding his
attempts at transparency and I was
wondering if anyone in the Biden
Administration was in touch with Baker
either regarding moderation decisions
that critics call political censorship
or regarding his transparency efforts
recently so it's up to private companies
to make these types of decisions we were
not involved I can say that we were not
involved you don't even need to do much
research on The Smoking Gun because this
Administration has admitted repeatedly
that they go out of their way to talk to
social media companies about posts that
they can take down
jensaki in July 2021. can you talk a
little bit more about this uh request
for tech companies to be
used to be companies and are there any
actions that the federal government can
take to ensure their cooperation because
we've seen from the start there's not a
lot of action on some of these platforms
sure uh well first we are in regular
touch with these social media platforms
uh and those engagements typically
happen through members of our senior
staff but also members of our covid-19
team given as Dr Murthy conveyed this is
a big issue of misinformation
specifically on the pandemic in terms of
actions Alex that we have taken or we're
working to take I should say from the
federal government we've increased
disinformation research and tracking
within the surgeon general's office
we're flagging problematic posts for
Facebook uh that's man it's wild guys I
know no matter how many times you see
this stuff it's like they lie about
everything but here's Karin jump here
just a couple days ago saying that oh no
we don't have anything to do with any of
this and then there's sake a year ago
saying yes we do flag posts senior what
did she say senior staff and the coven
folks they contact social media about
this information they were doing it they
told us that they were doing it and now
they're pretending that they didn't do
it